die winnetou affäre und ihre folgen
jetzt erfasst sie auch die
schlagerbranche cowboy und indianer
sie kennen den song das ist doch olaf
hennings größter hit seit 20 jahren beim
karneval im bierzelt oder beim après ski
genau hören wir doch einmal ein cowboy
und indianer und jetzt was wird aus
diesem hit komm cowboy und indianer
jetzt auf die schwarze liste des
schlages
[Musik]
da
ich finde es schon sehr lächerlich dass
das so enz gezogen wird
indianer ist ja diese indigene gruppe
die gibt es ja auch mal zuhauf aber ich
glaube dass das stört die selber gar
nicht schlagerstar olaf henning ist
bedient jetzt soll es also auch seinem
beliebten party hit an den kragen gehen
die sprach polizisten im land nähmen ihn
mal wieder ins visier
droht jetzt also auch dem harmlosen
partykracher über cowboys und indianer
alzheimer indigene völker die zensur
auch hier der vorwurf der deutsche
schlager klassiker bedingt angeblich
rassistische klischees
verharmlost nein noch schlimmer verhöhnt
das jahrhunderte lang andauernde leid
amerikanischer ureinwohner und indigener
gruppen und was sagt der schlagerbarde
selbst zu der debatte im moment haben
wir glaube ich weiß ganz andere probleme
als uns darüber aufzuregen
ob da jetzt cowboy und indianer
rassistisch ist oder nicht jeder kann
den lasso tanz ich mache mir überhaupt
keinen kopf darüber und jetzt ist gerade
genau in diesem moment ist dieses jetzt
erst recht und jetzt geben die so viel
gas und ich freue mich darüber und so
singt der schlagerstar vor kindern in
einer kita in nordrhein-westfalen eltern
verantwortliche der kindertagesstätte
und die kinder selbst luden den kult
sänger kurzerhand zu ihrem jährlichen
sommerfest ein um gemeinsam mit den
kindern deren lieblingssong von cowboys
und indianern zu singen
sehr darüber auch über diesen ausweg die
lieder kennt man seit jahrzehnten
und ich hatte den eindruck dass nicht
nur die kinder sehr viel spaß hatten
sondern auch die eltern wie vielleicht
sogar als gut an zeiten erinnert worden
sind doch eben längst nicht mehr bei
allen kommt der qualität so super an vor
allem der begriff des indianers stößt
einigen spaßbremsen sauer auf
im kindergarten st antonius scheut man
die auseinandersetzung mit dem durchaus
komplexen thema derweil nicht kita
leiterin margit huber ist darauf
vorbereitet
der kinder kommen werden wir in die
tiefe gehen und ihnen erklären es gibt
verschiedene indianer und es war auch
sicherlich früher nicht alles richtig
was passiert ist leider enteignungen usw
war nicht in ordnung aber das künstliche
dreijährigen gut sprechen aber es gibt
durchaus sehr kritische 56 jährige auf
nachfragen man darf die tatsächliche
geschichte nicht verdrängen als
erwachsener mensch da muss man immer
gerne sich rhein reichen und überlegen
ob es richtig oder falsch ist aber
ausklammern ist keine lösung sich mit
beschäftigen schon eher vielleicht keine
so schlechte einstellung denn mit einer
zensur des partyhits wäre hier definitiv
niemandem
[Musik]